as you can see here I got a burrito bowl
for lunch it's chicken lettuce rice
brown rice and no beans because you know
beans 15 people are watching me eat my
lunch right now
seriously I'm live-streaming this
through periscope Twitter's new live
streaming app of course by the time you
watch this it won't be live no not you
guys
still live for you right now anyway live
mobile streaming has become all the rage
right now heard of meerkat well that's
been gaining popularity and now here
comes periscope which also lets you beam
live video to all your Twitter followers
with just the tap of a button on the
home screen you can see your friends
live broadcasts for instance my friend
drew here just had a stem-cell
transplant
so he's been live streaming updates from
the hospital room all week while he
streams I can comment to him and tap to
heart or like his feet
broadcasting or going live is just as
easy tap on this button give your stream
a title and then hit start broadcast
then just wait for your adoring fans
together the hardest part is actually
figuring out how to hold your phone
anyway once you're finished making
history you can save it so people can
watch it later you can even see how many
people tuned in my problem and I'm
guessing yours is that there's nothing
very interesting to stream guys want to
see me eat chips but the founders of
periscope are betting that people really
do have interesting parts of their lives
to share that's what one of the
co-founders told me of course the
periscope audience to share what they're
doing with the people that they care
about right ok so if you have
interesting stuff to stream you can try
it out now periscope is available today
for iOS android is coming soon where are
you guys going I'm not even done eating
this come on
so I got really interesting